hello hello hello what's up everybody we
are here with game spot that
happy Monday by the way um I'm Persia
I'm here with Michael and we're gonna
play some rage - we go be raging and oh
my mic is is my mic hot it's extra hot
oh it's muy caliente
super hot boy let me not put my mouth
all up in this thing so blow up y'all's
ears but yeah we're gonna be playing a
rage - now ie my review went out this
morning this is H 2 is embargo lifted
and you can go check that out
not yet because we want you to stick
around in the street but yeah this is
our my first time streaming with Persia
I usually here with the Kuya Eric Tay
but I'm trying to help Eric out of Bay
gonna be seeing me more on the stream so
I'm excited for that and of course
playing these awesome games rage 2 comes
out tomorrow so let's play a little bit
of this check it out and then hopefully
you guys will pick it up and then after
this you guys can check out Michael's
awesome review sick beans let's start so
what we're gonna do here just to give
you a little taste of a little bit
everything we've gone through the first
30 minutes
and then we're gonna jump to a mid game
save so I can kind of show y'all a
little bit of what you get later on in
the game I know the juicy stuff there's
a lot of stuff in this game in terms of
abilities and stuff and uh some story
stuff which is massive amounts of
cutscenes like skipping everything only
cuz I wanted to like please yeah but the
cutscenes actually look pretty cool yeah
I mean it is a little I mean most games
start with a cutscene but but later on
like throughout the game they don't
really spend much time worrying about
that stuff
yeah so I mean and I say like hey I'm
thankful for that because you know story
is kind of it's more of just we're
trying to set a place up for you to do a
bunch of cool [ __ ] so there's not really
I'm gonna get any crazy lore out of it
which is fine you know not every game
needs to have
a deep story this game certainly doesn't
think that I mean I never really played
the first rage and I think that maybe
like there's probably people out there
who have also yeah right trying to spend
a little extra time you know hey yes
what we're about first
yeah there's um it doesn't that there
are there are parallels from rage one to
this game there are some returning
characters but none of it is like none
of it you need to know ahead of time so
they kind of have a clean slate in this
game cuz rage one came out a little
while ago so might not be a fresh in
people's minds also that game was like
really short and kind of not much going
on did some cool things but you know was
a little short on everything else a
little bit of the same here but uh I I
think they do a lot of cool interesting
stuff that they can definitely take in
another direction I have this game but
you know we'll see what's up with that
in a minute
this is general cross by the way he's a
bad dude that you got take down this
[ __ ] an [ __ ] so and there's
a bunch of mutants that you kill people
is heated you know you're one of the
many you hate it then it's like I don't
want to keep it throws but boy I love
watching the drama go down on Twitter
oh I'm here for the memes man the means
of production but yeah thank you for a
see crime in the chat I see Matt pageant
and oh [ __ ] man so baby okay so I saw
box night in here hello so check this
[ __ ] you want to welcome everyone here
join us so check the [ __ ] out you can
choose a dude or a girl
taking over yeah dude now watch this
[ __ ] so I'm like alright I'm gonna be
the homegirl here [ __ ] shit's going down
so this is vinyl in your home and
everything's about to go down at least
it was before they [ __ ] everything up
this is amateur game so mature stream so
yeah this so yeah I got my weapons I got
defend myself what's going on here when
I was playing I was like this feels very
like Bioshock esque right you know
Bioshock they always like take the extra
time yeah yeah yeah so if you didn't
know like I didn't notice this when I
first played this but so you can choose
a man or a woman and then whoever you
don't you just [ __ ] dies in the
beginning yeah you it's really hard it's
really easy to miss yeah yeah stop - so
Lily's like you're your best friend
[Music]
yeah it's it's so yeah over here is the
man version you could have chose yeah I
was like who is this oh wait that's cold
but it'd be like that sometimes the rage
already I know I'm always mad out here
okay so this is the beginning set up and
I got to shoot some fools this may look
and feel similar to do more Wolfenstein
because some software lineage up in this
game and it feels good like the movement
and the shooting feels pretty good yeah
just like most probably nowadays they
all follow they tend to follow the same
format yeah they kind of figured out how
to make shooters feel good at least on
console and
so yeah we're playing on PC by the way
and I usually do keyboard and mouse I
played mostly game on keyboard and mouse
but for the sake of simplicity with a
controller it controls really well to
you like in terms of mapping out your
buttons and stuff this there's a lot of
like pause screens telling you like aim
do this do that
yeah and later on the game it kind of
doesn't phase out I was like I still had
to go do some training even when you
start clearing out bases and stuff it's
like hey you clear out a base let's
pause the [ __ ] game the letter
hello G pro player thanks for tuning in
happy Monday yeah so the thing I like
about the very beginning of this game is
that it it just like it does so much it
doesn't like it doesn't give a [ __ ] like
so the whoever you didn't choose just
dust straight-up dies doesn't tell you
this dude who's supposed to be like
crazy like a badass super soldier just
gets eaten by this monster like whoa
dude like this game
it sets up like an attitude of where I
get a rate his body you're like well
yeah yeah but I need your soo dog like
it does a lot of it kind of subverts
your expectations a little bit in the
beginning just too bad it doesn't really
carry out throughout the rest of the
game but at least in the setup you know
let me just take this dead dudes body
yeah it's pretty funny because they
definitely made him look super bad I
could see like he's like sliding in yeah
like throws the canoe down so it was
like fruit enough not before he got to
zip it gets his head even so you know
okay so yep switch your westerns like an
assault you know okay yeah wing stick
all right cool
oh [ __ ] are we through oops my bad
Luther [ __ ] oh it's it's not the most
like later in the game it's not the most
useful thing but it is fun to mess
around with especially when you get like
lock-on abilities with it it's pretty
fun I use training aids so you tap down
toss that [ __ ] blow em up oh you got
explosive barrels here too so ya know it
took like half the clip the destroy them
things yeah so these are called felt
rates they're both currency and give you
a form of currency there's like two
currencies in this game but you don't
really need to pay attention to that
right now at least in the beginning
salt boy
splat wait come on there you go yeah
can't cancel my Barbie loads there's no
VX bees in this okay yeah yeah this
funny of Max and I were just talking
about that because we're playing Halo
the other day oh yeah I saw there is a
halo one on in the hilt is your favorite
actually like a clue oh really yeah
crazy okay I can see that yeah we're
saying like two or three probably
favorites yeah I would say two for like
ops here competitive game 3 for kind of
opening the world's eyes to the halo
competitive scene
yeah it really felt like a complete
package it freakin fell off super hard
and this halo 5 came out which I loved
I feel like that sometimes
it broke oh this gate is indestructible
whatever obviously my bullets it all
matters he'll stab myself you don't have
access to it yet but like there's like
this - mechanic in the game that's very
Halo 5s oh yeah I think is also similar
to something in Wolfenstein and/or game
but it's super useful and you can
upgrade it to do like a double dash
release trimly useful for later and get
bomb bucket on overdrive look at Super
Saiyan yeah it's just maybe like extra
powerful yeah it kind of um when you go
into overdrive you your weapons shoot in
a lot they kind of do a little bit more
auto aim but a lot more powerful and you
recharge oh yeah so it's kind of like
soldier boy 69 soul concentrate oh
please my wing stick yeah who's homegirl
he never really shows up in the rest of
the game I'm just disappointed cuz she
seems like she'd be a really dope
character suave suave says what was
y'all's favorite game so far of 2019
that's a going in going in deep on a on
a Monday morning probably so far metro
Exodus which I also reviewed because
honestly I just loved that game so much
yeah yeah I saw you was playing on a
stream last week
it was like my second time playing
Tetris 99 specifically like if I've
played a lot of touches on my life but
99 the whole new beast and it's really
fun but like I don't know what I'm gonna
switch so I've just been like firing
area oh really
you're like consistently in the top ten
and actually m1 I watched the segment
where you actually want
I played a bunch over the weekend and in
my thumb was so sore I had to like take
a break Chris yeah so yeah general cross
he's the bad dude he's just a bad dude
that's that's all profile obtained bad
dude yeah that's as much as you need to
know to be like the super bad guys close
combat and marksmanship that sounds way
over power and 15 I mean I was gonna say
something
you got a yeah nevermind it the game
isn't out yet so I'm not gonna talk
about late late game stuff yes but here
so here's another way in which the game
opens up by just saying like [ __ ]
everything that you think you know about
game openings like this characters
supposed to be or is built up to be like
a very important piece of the story but
she's like yeah so this game has like a
pretty pretty dope opening I would say
that much plot armor ECU so far except
for maybe our main card which is us we
were allowed to have the plot remember
a few original artists for
experimentation but for you hi Maxie
Mads dropping lines from my review and
the tag
thank you Matt sorry I didn't play seed
with you the other night Matt I was
reading my review ten times over to make
sure I didn't make any typos you know
yeah it'd be like that all the time so
she um irked yes you just got strips
damn good dog like no room or ease
yeah this is exactly the beginning has
no remorse yeah setup is pretty cool for
those of you interested rage to does
come out tomorrow so you know we just
want to just play it so you guys could
check it out see if you don't want to
pick it up we do have our own review
outs this score is a little low but
depends on your perception of what's a
low score but yeah you can get to check
that on the side it's a I gave it a 6
out of 10 I mean go ahead and read the
reviews what do you got time but that
doesn't mean that the game doesn't have
dope stuff right yeah so one thing I
dedicate a lot of time in the review
saying is I like combat and powers are
really cool which I'm gonna show off
okay right give this about like another
15 minutes then I'm gonna load a later
safe to kind of show you what I mean
when I say like the combat the the
variety of their powers and the weapons
really really shine like not many it's a
really stands out amongst a lot of other
first-person shooters so but then what
you'll also see is like that the
open-world activities are kind of
whatever no the main thing though for me
is that this game does does such a good
job of giving you tools to use and just
be like a badass but it never really
gives you the proper like setup
to use those powers like the main
missions like they're usually just end
by the time you start to get into a
group and like same thing with the side
stuff it's like oh yeah I clear all this
bana cap in like two minutes
where does everyone else what is
everything else so and it's like that
throughout the entire game which is
disappointing disappointing but again
six is not a bad score so I recognize
the cool [ __ ] that this game does yeah I
mean when it comes to reviewing a game
there's more than just hey how's the
game player like hey like what's combat
like or hey what what about this story
it's kind of all of that intertwining
together so even though you know 6 out
of 10 that doesn't necessarily mean that
you know every aspect of the game is
yeah exactly exactly
and like I said this on Twitter too is
like a people got different opinions
maybe so if you like if you like this
game like other reviews out there you
know they'll differ as well but you know
it's all good I mean oh yeah you know I
do know people who kind of don't like
games that force you to play many many
outright yeah hours to spin so you know
you can still play a game finish it go
get that sense of accomplishment from
beating the game yeah I mean still going
on with you like everybody has a lot of
time so yeah I totally I totally
understand that and I definitely feel
like that as well my dumb ass started
playing Final Fantasy 14 which is an
endless gaming but like for a while -
especially as I you know start working
full time and all this other [ __ ] is
that you know I wanted games to have a
beginning and an end and I want to just
get like a whole experience and maybe a
week if that so you know short but sweet
games are definitely dope the thing is
though it's like this game is short in
the sense that the main mission because
it's an open-world game so you spends a
significant amount of time going from
place to place and the main campaign you
can knock out about eight to ten hours
but a lot of that is spent you know go
to this location you talk to somebody
whereas something like doom that you can
knock out in about ten hours that game
just like non [ __ ] stop action all
the time so in that aspect that's kind
of where I was like ah man
I wish I wish this game kind of took
notes on that you know I'm Sam which
innocence isn't even you know a
testament saying that the game is fat
right right yes
leaving you wanting more exactly is
actually a good that's exactly what I
said to I'm like yo like y'all could
have gave me more and this game it would
have been it would have I felt like it
could have elevated the game a little
bit more by just like man give me more
because like you guy like there's
there's something here that's really
special
it's just yeah just wasn't enough of it
so you know maybe like DLC down the line
will really help improve the overall
package like because that'd be this
would be a wild PvP it would do it I
don't know what that would look like but
I'm sure that there's like an idea
floating around there that could really
put this game strengths strengths to use
but you know that's that's probably not
part of their creative vision maybe so
it's all good
but that would be it is cool thing about
what they could have done with that
stuff so yeah so we just said I had to
listen to that whole hologram of
probably talking to me about like the
setup and stuff this fine
but here is kind of introducing you to
arts arcs are these little pods that are
scattered throughout the open world map
that give you your dope abilities yeah
yeah which is which is cool because it
tells you like a you can use it like
this and you know okay so here's the -
yeah yeah tracer yeah that's akin to you
because you can upgrade the - tattoo you
can do to it two at once so I'm like
like going boom boom boom like I'm
playing like I'm [ __ ] tracer India
which is feels pretty cool oh yeah
oh it's yo ass out here boy you can't
see me yeah this is some of the training
that you do get when you get new
abilities - is really useful sometimes
forgot that I had it in my pocket to use
but yeah there's like some some boss
fights where you really need to remember
to - but for the most part it's more
like looking cool when I was in the
trails like okay I'm away til the rocket
is like pretty close to me and then on
the - and then I got hit by like blast
damage I was like oh okay - super really
yeah it's just learning the nuances of
the mechanic um some people on the chat
seem pretty unhappy there's no pvp but
you know especially in this era of DLC
who knows didn't wildlands not have a TV
and then they added a PvP maybe maybe
I'm not a hundred percent sure if that's
correct but some game recently like
added a PvP later on yeah yeah also so
doom 2016 launched with the PvP mode
which wasn't great actually it was
applied the weakest part of the game but
so I mean not especially when it comes
to shooters you know there they play
shooters a little less for the story
yeah it wasn't that great in Doom though
and then Wolfenstein both you order a
new Colossus didn't have PvP either
which was perfectly fine because that
game was already [ __ ] better oh yeah
this game follows suit but I mean with
all these abilities and crazy [ __ ] that
you can do it's like I don't man I want
to know what that would what that would
look like if they were to do something
like that
you would be pretty cool on the good
slate
I mean already feels so natural as a
shooter in general that it feels that
you would only transfer you yeah
we cannot tell the future we can only
wish and pray yeah so you're probably
wondering why I'm stuck I'm just like in
this room jumping around is because I
have to wait for this effort on to you
to stop talking Eric Andre my boy shots
off to Eric Andre for no reason asked us
what our favorite game of this year was
so I'm kind of curious to know what the
chats favorite game is because I mean
you guys are the game experts right
things
what is y'all's favorite game yeah oh
I'm curious to see what y'all have to
say I said Metro Exodus but yes there's
something else that I yeah i would say
Metro Exodus but Devil May Cry 5 is a
close second oh you know what spider-man
has been going so fast that I can't
easily cancel it like if the games came
out this year and I buy the spider-man
ones in our top games of 2018 yeah I was
like I really feel like spider-man they
make like the swinging capability is so
fluid yeah I was one of the most
impressive parts of it so there's a lot
of stuff going on here so you have
projects which are basically clear out
some open-world activities and then you
boost some things you get some things to
unlock some other things but these are
actually really cool perks so these are
there some of the basic ones that
they'll introduce you to so like yeah
you get a car and then you can get a
overdrive multiplier which makes your
overdrive even more
I would say and then some other cool
things here but yeah if you look through
that you can look through the menus even
before they're unlocked and there's like
a lot of cool [ __ ] like but your sprint
faster sprint while reload reload while
you holster your weapon like [ __ ] you
can knock back grenades you're such a
badass yeah yeah so you really feel like
you become a superhero I guess yeah
because it's like so much stuff here
we're starting to get some favorite
games with 2019 answers in we got to see
it's got a war scene that's their
favorite game ever
y'all just naming games right now
which is cool okay so we finally got to
the free roam section or free roam in
general this map so they start out by
marking a few arcs here so arcs again
like I said are the the pods where you
can unlock weapons and abilities so they
mark about four here or not about four
if they do mark four here then you can
go over it and check those out and then
these are the your main mission path so
just kind of set things up if you look
at your main mission path here you have
three different people you do missions
for or a mission for and then yeah you
do another mission and then you get to
the end of the game all right so it's a
few minutes before our half-hour
beginning always but now that I've seen
this map and I seen the screenshot of
your map in the review I feel like we we
should jump forward now yeah I think so
it'll be a it'll be a while till I
actually do anything more in this part
of the game so yeah so that was the
driving know a little bit I heard some
mixed things yeah it's it's weird on
controller it's fine
most vehicles control fine like the
Phoenix is your main thing and it feels
heavy but I don't mind that so much if
you're playing on keyboard and mouse boy
it's gonna be a
because vehicles do not control well on
keyboard a mouse so that's why I like it
in the shooting I use keep our mouse and
then whenever I had to drive a switch
over to a controller like I had both of
them hooked up at the same time because
it's it's not great but you know that's
alright so I'm going to load a yeah so
switch over it's your super special talk
to your account that Michael has been
working on so we can see some more of
the coolest stuff you guys can check out
what the map looks like later on into
the game because the map is crazy you're
like well we just saw the map compared
to you like how much [ __ ] you have on
the map after you play a little while
it's it's pretty
let's check show them that map just so
they can see yeah so know it eventually
it opens up of course like open-world
games should yeah here yeah bunch of
these question marks kind of show you a
little bit of where you can go to find
some of the cool stuff all the way yeah
this the save is about say I spent about
maybe seven ish hours to get to this
point
yeah so let me check out what abilities
I had in this safe cuz yeah this is a
mid game save that okay so I have a
bunch of stuff I haven't unlocked yet
what's important is that I have slam -
and overdrive grab no shot she had
shatters so those are like the main
abilities vortex is really cool rush is
really cool but at this point I don't
have him yet I think it might be able to
dig them up based on the map I've pulled
up for late game stuff so I can find
where the unlock that stuff because I
don't remember off the top mob raining
yeah and I still have at this point I'll
have some weapons to unlock as well
charge pulse cannons cool hyper cannons
really cool grabbed out a dart launcher
is fun
not not effective but it's real fun to
use yeah this will debate the basic set
up though if you want to be like super
effective is saw rifle shotgun and
rocket launcher let me see if I can no I
don't have enough I spent all my Nano
traits or all my fell traits
yeah like I was saying like with
projects you can get all these cool
perks so I got a couple perks here you
know I'm saying a little bit so what I
would suggest for those who play rage to
you is say [ __ ] driving you only drive
once you unlock the Icarus gyrocopter
pay 10 bucks and then you can start
flying everywhere yeah I was thinking
about that too like dude if I can get
one I won't have to worry about traffic
or taking BART to work I could Park this
on the roof I'm not gonna take up that
much space people's gonna be crashing
into each other all time bound to happen
I'd be like that
ok so let's actually let's try to do
something let's rage yeah let's let's
ring let me rage on I'm mad I clear out
a bunch of stuff let's see I want to do
something that's like level maybe 7 and
difficulty what's the highest level so
yeah yeah every time you get an activity
on your map it kind of gives you a gauge
of how hard it's gonna be for come on so
this is a bandit den which is just like
clear out of camp and it's a bit a bit
of ways out there but you know what we
don't got a drive so I'm just gonna fly
over there and do it there's no fast
travel there is fast travel but you can
only faster off with certain location
[Music]
also I can't faster I'll warm in this
thing so I'm gonna in the land and then
try and get to a closer spot actually
it's not actually it's not gonna save
that much time
like I want to show you a little bit of
the world toxic dump so these two follow
me this is the open world which is yeah
open worlds been a very popular
direction in games and sunny 19 yeah
it's um seems like such a challenge
though to build out an open world does
it I'm at least something fulfilling
enough that's gonna like satisfy
everyone at home that yeah that that's
kind of a struggle at least I've seen as
someone who plays these games of course
is you can build an expansive world
that's a lot of space but what you fill
it with is it's like it's hard to do - I
imagine it's hard to fill it out with
constantly like rewarding things to do
and that's kind of where this game
struggles a little bit or actually quite
a bit I would say I almost feel like
Skyrim has ruined it for everybody I
mean I had friends and family who just
could not get off of that right yeah
took me like literally like two hours
just to design my character because
there were so many things to customize
and then I was like okay I have my
character set the tone I guess because
you know seeing all the other open world
games in comparison it's like I see what
they're going for
okay so this is the mission we made it
yeah so look at that so I use focus yeah
so focus is uh yours where how you
enable your super abilities but it also
lets you see through walls if enemies
are close enough so I could see where
all these fools are at and I'm gonna
show you a little my favorite ability
here oh but there guns blazing now yeah
blaze up pick up the shotty I gotta get
out of here
they don't know how to cook your name
for ya what kind of outpost is I always
wonder where like hide out some stuff
get their goons from because they're
never smart horrible shadows ya shotgun
in this game is the best weapon it's not
the most fancy but it is the most
effective and if you do 80's if you aim
down sights it kind of acts as like a
like a force push or like a Gauss rifle
or something
it's not terribly accurate nah man
if he goes that far that's cheap I know
is it get up on these Joe ass out of
here boy that's it you're done son that
was level 6 difficulty level 6
difficulty I mean we could raise the
overall difficulty I am playing on
normal I tried a little bit of stuff on
hard and it's um it's got to be a little
bit more careful about where you are
yeah I just have to think more about
your health and using overdrive so I had
to overdrive the whole time and I didn't
use it and I really feel like I need it
too but what's you playing hard
definitely wants to incorporate that
first survivability let me see if I can
get back to my well I got the double
dash in this one boom see if I can trace
her up in this where did I park my I
could call another one for 10 bucks but
I'm broke so I need to say that more
right it's Monday a Friday's long we
actually got a walk
we got pay on Thursdays here so at least
we get an extra like a day earlier
actually [ __ ] it $10 ain't no thing
let's call it a ball way no no budget
$10 for a gyrocopter I'm down yeah so I
was a level 6 bandit then
you see if there's you clear out another
one
yeah sure let's do it let's go to the
one that was actually marked on the map
now when I just came across and I
decided to give them a little piece of
my mind
a couple people in the chat or like yeah
Skyrim's legendary in the middle like
nice guy rooms okay
see everyone tied up their own opinion
on gay scarves okay all right
some you said they came from Skyrim so I
feel like if you you came from Skyrim
then you're really gonna have a hard
time finding another open-world game
that you're gonna like as much so
I remember this particular bandit then
this one's pretty cool this is one of
probably the better ones out here
because it kind of funnels you through a
interesting location yeah some of the
enemies take quite a few bullets which
is actually pretty cool I like that box
wait $10 real money or in game yeah
they're not trying to they're not
juicing what Mike there's no
microtransaction IRL money PayPal cash
at venmo what imagine once once these
[ __ ] video games started integrating
venmo installation it's over yo that's
nasty broth wash yo ass yeah so that
force pushes really cool ability along
with oh I'm not the [ __ ] these what's up
y'all oh yeah
oh I think you hit a barrel yeah there
was some there are some barrels in there
and does area effect damage so there's
barrels there's oh oh it's going
overdrive yeah
we need to power up real quick fire yeah
it basically Auto aims for you it's a
gotta get some hacks for a minute aimbot
we all y'all see us players out there I
know y'all be trying aimbot [ __ ] I tried
using aimbot in counter-strike 1.6 when
I was like 14 just to see what it was on
a burner account that [ __ ] was wild dude
I'll never forget like the halo 2
modders was insane like they would have
a br and each bullet was like a sniper
bullet and it was auto aim it's like one
shot they would like glitch outside the
map that's like super jumps oh yeah this
is busted then you would try to bridge
connection so you get hosts every time
so you didn't catch my oh yeah yeah and
then that would take forever those are
the big actually I'm glad that I know
what in many ways I'm glad to like you
can't pull that [ __ ] as there's still
hackers out there but of course it's a
lot less you were 1 million percent a
hacker yeah how do you keep up that
because I hail ago you said halo 3
selling 50 ranked accounts that should
ran on yellow right it was wasn't it oh
I think I had both like an elo
matchmaking rank and also like an
overall rank or whatever I think yeah
max what units basically people close to
your level or some people would party up
with like low levels make it really hard
to like Matt oh yeah that's [ __ ] up
boosters boosters there supposed to be a
big-ass fool here somewhere so i'ma say
my overdrive gosh chemical rocket
launcher
all these holes watch out oh there is
way I'm trying to get a direct hit
hey don't suction these rocks Rocco says
game feels like doom in the world
I like math Mass Effect and Mass Effect
feel like if you're like Mako Mako
sequences in Mass Effect one and it's
kind of like that right the goons are
eliminated eliminated them goons goon
squad and here are our chests which have
valuable currency for you to unlock more
powers or upgrade to cars they want to
see you struggle this yeah you meet you
just do you good I mean ma'am one I'm
too good to I struggle too much and real
life to be struggling hmm here's a level
eight crusher nest so this might be can
you change the difficulty of the game
maybe more so I'm gonna go into a lovely
let's make you suffer sure this is all a
men don't I'm not gonna okay okay well I
actually don't know what how it how it
changes difficulty but we're gonna find
out it says eight set the difficulty of
the game and let's set it on nightmare
I'll see how much of a nightmare this
actually goes you know most games they
have that one level that's higher than
like hard and it's always some crazy
name instead of just like extra hard
limits yeah nightmare doom and
Wolfenstein both do the head of soul
okay so we're on nightmare mode so if I
die we get to talk about how bad you are
if I die he dies he dies but we do this
for you that's all good alright so I'm
gonna take my gyrocopter to this level
eight crusher nest
yeah level eight which is probably now
like level 18
Nightmare Moon we'll see I played a
little bit on hard and it was a little
bit more challenging but nightmare I
don't know if this maybe like eight two
shots you're done son
you know some games they do different
things in difficulty right it's either
you know the harder it is the opponents
like have more resistance and they do
more damage or they aim better a little
smarter yeah there's a lot of ways in
which you can make difficulty change and
I don't know how nightmare I'm gonna
give it a little test here so this is a
level 5 bandit camp here or fuel depot
and you know it's not supposed to be
that difficult but it's yeah okay on the
way to the lovely so this is I need to
warm up a little bit what's up okay he's
trying to seem approach as unnormal yeah
so far so good you might get less health
back when you kill an enemy yeah I like
when you go into like oh all the needs
oh what's up y'all right next to the
barrel I think I took out a barrel too
so good cuz that's what I need to do in
this area okay three shot e shots
compared to the one just do it anyone
sit on up
[Music]
now you're just that good that's what it
is I am taking a quite a bit more damage
I'll say that much there I want to see
if they're a little bit smarter did you
really be thrown aid they kind of like
trip on themselves I'm trying to get out
of the way but they're actually just
like straight tripping yeah I mean I'm
taking a lot more damage so I got a
things out ejecting myself
great only on video games will we inject
ourselves with something some strange
liquid with no with no don't ask why no
hesitation don't not be I wasted my
overdrive I thought there was more
people
hey let's hide in this room full of gas
this fuel see okay yeah okay so I wasn't
I think I may have oh yeah but I have to
destroy this container so I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna take care of that real
footage kara says I'm gonna double-check
maybe is I says can you curb stomp you
can stomp yeah if you if you usually
melee hits won't kill enemies in one go
but if you get them on the ground and
then you may leave them it turns into an
automatic stomp which is you'll see
their heads explode which is boy yeah
I'll take it
and with that we have direct eyes view
oh there's one more which one did I not
explode Oh what very difficulty finding
the last last barrel there it is oh it's
up there [ __ ]
well there you go that's my nightmare
okay so but that was a level 5 camp so
let me try that
can you grapple hook in this game slide
while running you just crowd ohh not
into the middle post there's also a perk
for if you slide and overdrive you can
combine that into a melee hit I think
and then like knock them up in the air
which is not useful but it's cool you
know I don't want to be on nightmare
mode all I'll be sliding into crowds of
enemies
yes it's some combos yeah I wish I could
but I don't yeah also they're just not
like enemies aren't really set up that
way so I wish it was you know like doing
cool things like throwing I don't have
the vortex ability but I got it later in
the game and it's really cool because
you could just throw and then they all
the enemies will gravitate towards your
thing you throw and from there you can
do some really cool things like yeah
combine it with your shatter ability and
then let them fly and just like shoot a
damn rocket up in them pieces everywhere
yeah so there's a lot of cool things
that you can do they're just gangs been
in that $10 again I spent $30 on
gyrocopters man I need to log that into
my expensive I'll just expensive are
they're mainly weapon says Daedric
gaming nah just just your melee ability
cool boomerangs
not really a million oh yeah even if
there was melee weapons I don't think I
would ever use them I think there's a
there's enough at your disposal that you
don't really meet to melee really but
yeah I don't know that okay I'm safe
there's some areas where if you're the
way the gyrocopter works is that it's
the the height of its flight is all
relative to the ground below you so I'm
like slowly descending even though I'm
trying to fly higher the way the way you
get hires get closer to higher ground
and go oh [ __ ] wait I was supposed to go
there I went off the map bro it's as if
you died oh okay interesting
yeah I fell too far into the canyon you
got to be careful next time
yeah like you can't really control your
altitude all that much what you get
close to higher things in the higher
geometry it'll catapult you up from
there so like watch a [ __ ] oh I'm
getting close to this rock
okay oh that was a good example
sorry doesn't work with trees yeah so
I'm gonna go into this jungle area so
this northern section is all jungle
stuff and it's it looks pretty dope I
like this area a lot I just wish there
were they used it more like in the main
story they only take you through there
once and there's just like so much like
lush jungle land there that I wish I was
like there's like nothing on oh yeah not
much going on there but it's a cool area
and we'll see that in a minute okay got
to make sure I don't fall into the
canyon again got my ass ass sent back to
that a fuel depot it's so funny you
couldn't just like fly across it like
nope I could I just gotta be so if I
fall there I'm gonna get reset but I'm
gonna stay close to this edge here so I
can catapult myself
oh okay yeah so what are these like side
missions that you can just hop in on
yeah these are like a little emergent
activities you this one is a convoy
there's like a big-ass trucks and trains
that kind of just drive around the map
when you come across them you engage in
this sort of car combat mode the
gyrocopter does have any weapons on them
so there's actually nothing I can do
right now so I'm just spectating but if
you had like your Phoenix car with with
some cannons and rocket launchers you
take them down and you get like a whole
bunch of auto parts to then upgrade so
people shooting at it now are those a
eyes that you also take them out - yeah
they're all part of the convoy you try
to shoot at me oh hang on oh damn my my
oh I just passed by them oh yeah I got a
piece out that was our train of thought
actually train the dogs okay
[Music]
the Oh Joe you got a got a challenge
ourselves oh this I know I know what
this one is this is uh you fight two
big-ass monsters this is probably gonna
be hard yes
I don't think I have many rockets Roger
best
I'm just gonna land right here
I got a kill digging dug is this game in
third-person view I think only her when
you're in the vehicle it really [ __ ] I
don't have to rocket and I don't have
this is extra nightmare mode okay this
might be difficult
we'll see I play Dark Souls before he's
got dodge at the right time war day at
doe so we know where oh he is big so bro
oh oh yeah these [ __ ] got like
wave ability and they got teamwork he
was like you know hit my homie he's
gonna turn his back on you get your ass
back here I know
nowhere else sees it that was my only
health effusion - so I gotta do this all
right now
black snake says extra spicy yeah oh
he's staying on nightmare mode got a
word don't you worry about it
we have foursome to undergo this there's
no backing out now I open Pandora's box
I'm so [ __ ] use my Rockets right now
boy let's go what else I got my wings
take a van - [ __ ] ow
18:18 health left the problem is there's
no other like minions or
what'd he call him in like bubblers
creeps to build up to build up my
overdrive you build up overdrive by
killing eggs and there's no enemies The
Kills and your health does not
regenerate on its own no but I got
defend one more chance this is actually
a cool feature oh but I'm gonna die real
soon anyways so [ __ ] it no you got this
I have to have something nearby yeah I
could probably I don't know if I get too
far away if his health will regenerate
because that happens in some games I
don't know if it's this one I don't want
to bother him either sorry
mics are high where are all the pickups
you know what that might be a thing of
nightmare mode less pickups maybe I
don't really notice it on hard but you
know nightmare might be a whole
different thing
hey jerk says you get better with
challenge that is some wise words no
lies detective Oh looks like around the
perimeter at least I can't find [ __ ] but
let's see if our health regen or
whatever I'm gonna take this fool out
take out I'm backing myself into it I'm
backing myself into a quarter done son
if you don't get some health off of
taking him down like my wave glands
that's something you take to a vendor to
like upgrade some stuff but he doesn't
drop any pickups so I'm gonna have to
take out this next dude with no shotgun
shells no rocket launcher and no healing
and 15 home and just myself so it's
gonna be kind of like you know like
destiny style a bullet sponge but the
main thing here is to dodge tax like
forgot what a tailgate yeah
[Applause]
you got this you definitely got this no
it's all about dodging man yeah a little
bit rapid-fire we'll turn around and say
right here's like our and turn around
just wrong oh that barrels it's okay
when I was playing the operation Oracle
I definitely indicted to an explosion
barrel that was standing next to I was
like what am i dangerous good in what we
have how we on time okay so that's 35
minutes you know what I'm going to take
these fools down but to do that we need
yeah so what I'm gonna do is just read
fashion oh there's a town here forgot
where I think it mmm
might be there I'll go check that out
real quick because I need something I
need some resources so let me see $40
now watch out you guys got there how do
you dodge so it's not a warrior it's
left bumper just tap that left bumper
and you do a cool dodge ability super
useful especially apparently if you're
playing on that remote or if you fight
if you find a lot of those bigger
monsters they usually do some pretty
heavy attacks that you can kind of
Telegraph I suppose and then yeah
definitely easier dodge that's um
it's a bandit camp back there that's
level 8 maybe I could do that as well a
nightmare mode but before we get there
kind of thing you should have gone for
the head he's wearing helmet
he's one they better shoot him in the
face where's is helmets not protecting
but maybe that's a good idea
disgustin here's a town where I could
probably try and stock up on some things
thing even though we just spent 40 bucks
on traveling
now I gotta go more than that paper yeah
they used dollar bills yeah what do you
sell
I don't need that [ __ ] okay here we go
it's uh I can craft health infusions but
yeah five bucks whatever I got overdrive
infusions which also might come in handy
some use that infusion for six when you
start out you hold four and then you can
upgrade to six and then eight for now
and the save I got six
yeah upgrade schematics let you do make
them more dank more potent so shotgun
shells make sure I maxed out on that
rockets I need them okay so I'm stocked
up on rockets and shotgun shells and
health I got I got the ability in out of
the overdrive infusion set these fools
is going that's bold alright oh so
you're putting words in my mouth
at this point yeah hey you took down one
of the big boys yeah I almost have you
there there it was the barrel wasn't
even hit
yeah froze yeah barrel took me out so
you really do anything but yeah the I
would say it well [ __ ] whoops whoopsies
it's all good okay
Java copter can recalibrate itself what
they all say is that the you know once
you learn their attack patterns it's um
just don't mess up and you'll be fine
but let's see if I'll mess up it's like
boss battles 101 there's always gonna be
an impact
attack pattern and just you know play
smart rocket cheese in just like
straight up be up on these uh on those
buildings I play this range from above I
play to win the game
oh [ __ ] I want to get out before Oh
all right there I got land man let me
land
all right let's I'll take them down
myself not gonna cheese I'm not gonna
cheese
okay basher and Smasher dig and dug the
name is actually kind of adorable yeah
come at me bro
it's got a lot better just throwing [ __ ]
man oh man I was like too late on the
dodge although being conservative a [ __ ]
like man I bought like max damage big
boy seasoned infuse myself so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take care we're
drivin fusion and then go to shot the
shotgun in overdrive is really good I
need it oh [ __ ] whoops Isaac - so yeah
blacksmith that's usually me when I play
Vera I'm like justice cuz I guess that
wasn't as effective as I thought yeah
back to the rock back to rocket launcher
I know [ __ ] sorrow now we're nimble
we're quick for a light on our feet
over previous back now he's just getting
frustrated he's rage quitting
he's mashing you're just mashing at that
point man a you know I hit him with the
juggling them with these Rockets boy so
yeah that was big and Doug as long as
you can touch being decent dang big and
Doug they got buddy
they did they got got so that was a
level eight mutant nest thingy I passed
by it so I passed by a so here's okay
well I'll show you what this century
Authority centuries are probably the
worst side activity in this game oh no
they're they're not that bad but they're
like worse in what sense like difficult
playing yeah they're not that they're
not that fun
it's they're basically like this yeah
just like this big-ass turret that
shoots lasers at you and you got to
dodge them it's pretty challenging
especially the level the higher level
ones they're they're challenging but
overall you just kind of like bullet
sponge a turret so it's not yeah well
the string wants to see you suffer so I
think cuz yeah this one is pretty tough
some tough stuff
I can cheese it alright I'll try it for
reals and then if I die then I'll cheese
it
there's I have a have a way I tried this
the other day I only have two Rockets
right next I'm gonna have to rely
actually the assault rifle is probably
one of the better options for taking out
sentry drones
oh I'm out guns blazing bro
yeah this is taking a lot more damage -
oh [ __ ] I know so that was it we
difficult so you have to like time it as
it goes oh boy oh I'm done son
I dodge too early not your find your
character is definitely late I should
probably help ya my dumb ass over yeah I
was wasted this thing is taking a lot of
damage oh he's got like hella it's
nightmare armor yeah fruits ah that's it
that one was quick yeah that was real
quick so in that in that case let me try
and cheat this so what you do is I got
actually I'm gonna back up for a moment
chill bro get out my lawn
yeah froze alright let's call in I'd
never mind
I can't once I finish one of the
missions you unlock this big-ass tank
and then what you can do is every time
you get in the big-ass tank this the
drone clams up but what you do is it
takes a moment so you get in the tank
you get out it's right it opens up you
start shooting it while it's trying to
open up and they get back in the tank
and then it closes up again you just
keep doing that for like five minutes
and then you're good yeah but I can't do
that so you know what I'm not gonna
can't cheese it yeah I like cheese
actually want to try I said okay I just
bought another drone or another
gyrocopter so that's warped at 50 bucks
I might pronounce this wrong but louisia
says not many games do split-screen
anymore but Borderlands does and that's
epic yeah I didn't know I was like
definitely not that many split-screen
games out anymore and I tend to really
like playing like offline co-op games
that is not yeah it's like there's so
few of those nowadays like cut that was
really fun and oh yeah Castle Crashers
great over cookies really fun too
there was also this other like
two-player co-op game where you're like
escaping from prison with your friend
and a way out right yeah yeah that one's
fun too yeah that one's actually it's a
good time
it's not like them it's not like the
best game but like it's if you have if
you have if you're doing that with like
a good friend yeah it's a fun time it's
pretty it's like it's like pretty silly
fun also we're like a more serious
LittleBigPlanet almost because they use
each other to like get into certain
places and everything that reminds me
unravelled is very good as well the one
where he was like a little ball of yarn
he uses it to like swing across stuff
yeah thank you
here I'm going to do some racing oh my
god shut yo ass I don't like anything
even resembling like an office garden
like there's a way out mess me up on the
real how do you do my races bro harsh
says I just can't wait for a halo
infinite you'll be waiting a long ass
time that's cool
I'm excited too I mean I'm always
excited for another halo game and then
once I play it even I really decide if
I'm gonna be playing it or not yeah but
you know I think a little part of my
heart is always gonna be
a halo fangirl yeah it's uh to play with
homies who are tried to try Ken to MLG
actually one of my friends from high
schools like legit I'm LG's status in
halo but he's also a bodybuilder so he's
like yeah yeah oh he was going to
bodybuilding competitions and playing
Halo 4 MLG okay smash we are actually
playing on PC but we're using a
controller yeah control what do I talk
to our races yeah it's very rude okay
shut us up bro I want a race I don't
know what to talk to my bad just gotta
like pull your car up to them have a
girl like a little handkerchief and then
they know you're ready to race yeah
taught me anything that's how you
initiate it or honk three times sooner
I've done I used to be a racer so I
guess when we're not doing races yeah I
did the whole thing I'm a catback
exhaust I had I had headers which are
illegal I had my cold air intake how
many times did you say spooling none
because I know because I didn't have a
supercharged or a turbo I don't know why
all my racer friends that was like their
favourite word I'm like oh I hope they
had like a turbocharged car because
that's what spooling is yeah I used to I
used to do and I used to be an amateur
race car driver I talk about this a lot
with uh with tay and stuff but i think i
may have mentioned this on screen before
but it's how many feet tall warrior
spoilers that is the true testament of
how much ash i guess it wasn't that much
of a righteous man cuz I was like if you
rockin like some wack-ass spoilers like
that's me
sure oh I want to do a recharge station
these are actually pretty cool probably
a ver 't open-world activity it's just
like a wave based thing but it's it can
get pretty overwhelming yeah did you
ever worry ever into the important scene
at all I mean my brother was super into
it so I would tag along with him
sometimes to like crime eats which was
fun one of my first Jobs was actually at
an auto shop oh yeah but I think at a
certain point we like took our separate
paths right like he was like all right
I'm all in on cars I was like I'm all in
on video games yeah you gotta choose
your path at some point in life yeah I
think I think at one point you and my
brother was like games are your thing
and cars are my thing okay so handle
territory for me it was just like it's
really expensive and I was like I can't
afford this stuff oh yeah I got to a
point where yeah it's just really
expensive and my car broke down so I
bought a 350z and then I was like I'm
gonna get into this again but then of
like health I need to get to work and
make sure my car doesn't cause I'm also
like too lazy to drive stick
oh yeah driving stick man only drives I
don't drive anymore
yeah it's oh no I'm from I'm not from
San Francisco I don't even I don't drive
here so Ivan yes my car is in San Diego
where I'm from but I would not drive
here Oh what the [ __ ] they have a rocket
launcher then you punched him and then
blasted
he had to come in he's just a pile of
blood and armor yeah have any guts left
what happens in rage so I got a couple
enemies out here so once I hit that
charge station waves are gonna come at
me but I want to make sure I'm in the
clear before that get some resources you
know make sure I'm stocked up and [ __ ]
I'll playing some sick tunes here these
guys are pretty heavy heart yeah they
are armored I think of a different
strategy yeah he took a whole clip I
know your name with a mac-10 on the side
of my hip somebody yeah some of these
armored enemies are actually pretty
challenging so yeah I take a lot of more
damage I started this and I'm about to
die that's right it's like [ __ ] story
yeah okay we still died we didn't even
get started yet no I'm getting blasted
already bro
Fox my ass how is the public
transportation in Cali okay so I'm from
New York and so I'll always think like
New York has the best public
transportation san Francisco's not bad
like the BART and the Cal training the
Bart's will similar to like MTA and
Caltrans kind of like Amtrak the thing
about New York public transit is that
everyone it's like a collective effort
in the suffering like everyone yeah
there's a there's a sense of camaraderie
on New York public transportation right
yeah out here in San Francisco at least
everyone is like nah I'm all about me me
me me oh really
but the things on New York is like it's
24 hours you know it never stops running
there's no last train you have to catch
oh really
yeah it depends like the city's very in
California terms of like how good their
public transit is like San Diego they
ain't got [ __ ] really in terms of public
transit but out here in San so that's
like the main way you get around yeah
we're walking I think that was actually
one of my most favorite things about
living in the city is if you can walk
everywhere unless you're going to a
different Baroni me
but walking is pretty effective Oh New
York yeah oh snap bauxite lives in New
York actually oh snap shout outs New
York homies my father was born in East
Islip Long Island oh my gosh if I stay
over here I don't want to spread myself
so thin Nesmith sir says is this
multiplayer this is not we are playing a
mission a wave mission right now zero
says New York best public transport what
universe is you from I'm from my own
universe honestly I mean when I say best
in America best as in like you know it's
clean or the people are nice I just
think best as in like there's always
trans unless it's late for work but then
it's 24 hours yeah I think maybe I got
very immune to the to the graininess
like MTA during my like 10 years or
let's just say the bars low or my
tolerances I definitely yeah yeah I can
see that the problem san diego public
trans is that [ __ ] don't take you
nowhere don't go in yeah the problem
here is that like shits busted and it's
really grimy but you know it works you
know I'm not I'm not both like when I
first moved to New York compared to when
I moved out of New York the transit was
kind of going downhill only because I
felt like it was getting more and more
busy and more and more crowded which was
causing more and more delays like you
know it was just population now that's
what started making it really stressful
like there's just so many people so
maybe you know not enough trains they
should like be doubling up on the amount
of train right obviously that comes like
fare hikes like when I first moved to
New York it was 225 when I
left it was three dollars no [ __ ] or
like it was about to be three dollars
like 275 and they were just reporting
like a fare hike box and I can let me
know if it's gone up by now but I
remember that being the most recent like
fare hike change
yeah that's not that's up to you alright
y'all think it's always just 50 cents
that's 50 cents two times everyday
great doodad says are you guys excited
for a halo on Steam and have you heard
anything about a date on it I will say I
had no idea it was coming to steam but I
think that's awesome
yeah halo on PC Master Chief collection
is going to be rolled out on PC as far
as I know
starting with reach I don't know when
though no I think it's going to start
with the reach and combat Evolved and
then go from like 200 because the big
deal with like the last I think it was
an inside Xbox thing is that they said a
we're bringing reach to Master Chief
collection because it originally it
didn't come with it yeah okay sure yeah
single-player wise it was probably one
of the ones but yeah multiplayer I I did
like the reach multiplayer but I suppose
was probably the least popular yes this
game does come out to Mario you guys so
check it out yeah you know if you if you
enjoy this type of thing yeah oh yeah
you playing a lot of days gone oh yeah
he was playing wild lands to get ready
for that a breakpoint oh yeah reveal
which looks really good yeah and I'm
like definitely Jon Bernthal fangirls I
was like yes now I played Oracle and I
was like this mission is show so sure
you didn't do like the due diligence of
giving me a maximum Jon Bernthal and
then they're like well we have a game
for new
and I was like yes I knew it there is a
reason why you know I did that recharge
station it was level six nice box - it's
still 275 for the Baron good for you
guys when I first read it was going to
three dollars I was like dang this is
hurtin you know what's messed up is here
Bart fares are more expensive if you pay
with if you don't have a clipper card
yeah I did that one time because I left
my clipper car so I had to pay with cash
to get a single ticket charge you $50
more one-way I'm like $50 $50 okay
alright this space looks a little
serious this one is pretty cool it's got
some verticality going on some level
wars and of course hanging explosion
barrels because when you're a goon and
your goon hideout you have to hang up
some explosion barrels that's it
the Goonies oh what's up bro oh look at
that so shatter is really cool when you
can get people together like that
everyone just comes together and you can
just like shove them into oblivion yeah
so I'm gonna actually take out enemies
before I start shooting these barrels
cuz that's what I got it to here that's
got to destroy barrels cuz it be like
that sometimes 0hx see says open-world
games need a shake-up oh I was waiting
for my cooldown to get back play I would
see like a lot of open world games right
now they definitely are sharing like a
ton of similarities but honestly I'm
like what could they do to shake things
up I had the answer I would be a game
developer like if you could if you end
this questions for you guys see the
tuning in if you could add something new
and fresh to an open-world game that you
know hasn't been done yet what would it
be right it takes you to be like we need
to shake things up
oh wow that's the real question out
which you know I kind of feel like
breakpoint is trying to embark a little
bit on you know making things different
but not so much in terms of the world
itself but in terms of you as the
character right damaged and it's like
damage over time that will hinder your
character and you have to heal yourself
it's not just gonna regenerate on its
own and stuff like that that's new
that's cause it seems like they're
they're challenging you in different
ways but also giving you a lot more to
work with at the same time and I think
that's pretty cool because I like having
a lot of tools and figure out effective
ways to use them and also being
challenged to use them in clever ways
just one thing this game rage to kind of
but you know it's alright I'm not gonna
it does other things those other things
yeah don't throw my [ __ ] wing stick
at this [ __ ] blow it up for wing sticks
great doodad says in Montreal our
transit of 325 each way from in the city
but if we have different but we have
different Faris for different zones of
the cities oh yeah that's like that here
too like if you're going further away
your fares gonna cost more and I hate
that I really do I think that's also me
being spoiled in New York is that it you
know 275 we're gonna go wherever the
public transit can take you yeah it is
kind of it takes like from here to the
airport it's like nine dollars one-way
mystical Nisha says I love watching your
stream thank you we love that you guys
watch this stream team and we have a lot
of previous appreciation for people who
can stream because it is difficult and
we're happy to have Persia join us
recently because you know I represent
out here too you know you know you can
throw some props your way because we've
been handling this nightmare mode oh
sure it's uh yeah okay they're good yeah
what do you get once you get to grips
with somebody I don't even have like all
the way like in this save I don't handle
II have
the outside only have half my weapons
only have half of the actual cooldown
abilities now I'm playing on nightmare
mode so it seems fairly manageable is
what I'll say go ahead Chris Hawk says
what about an open-world game that
becomes more linear as you play it
depending on choices that would be cool
because you know you're starting out
with all these different options at
first and then your decisions would
change what you're able to do later on I
imagined that imagine that would be hard
to do because I think I think the at
least how I perceive is that if you
build a big open world psyche it's
really expensive and time-consuming but
I mean companies take risks sometimes
that could improve replay value you know
and go through it again try to get
different endings oh man what was that
game where everyone was kind of like a
human was it Detroit Detroit become here
yeah Detroit become human where that
kind of like determine your story to
plan your decisions that was a really
open world though yeah choice based
stuff is also evolved a lot over the
over the years I think my first
introduction what to it was the original
Deus Ex back in 2000 when choices kind
of affected outcomes and obviously it's
evolved a lot with Mass Effect in 2007
really taking that to new heights and
then Witcher in 2015 taking that to even
higher heights so the bar has been
pretty high in terms of like how do you
make decisions like meaningful that's
also another hard thing to account for
when you try to build a story it's like
I want to write a story but if I have to
think about all these different
branching paths take a lot of time and
effort so it's like those books
Bandersnatch yeah or gusta I used to
read Goosebumps books that gay that gave
you a choice is to it's like yeah those
were doable I was like you know people
make books like that that's cool I
remember I had a project in elementary
school where you know you had to write a
story and I tried to write something
like that it was like 19 pages
yeah and then you know in school they
teach you how to do like first draft and
then the second draft and then the final
copy by the final copy I was like why in
the world that I decide to do this
you're thinking like why does anyone
right now I get paid to write not books
speaking of that I in eighth grade we
had to write a story like a like a
nonfiction story or whatever it's just
for shits and giggles speaking of Deus
Ex is uh I basically like copy that
story banking so I'm incriminate myself
I was like hey Wayne what if I retold
the story of Deus Ex but with different
characters Oh
J'son never no no no unless he really
liked one of those lucky kids who's like
my teacher totally plays video games and
let's just go to recess early look he's
my friend you know everybody had at
least one of those futures growing up
yes I miss my future I'm in school I was
I still got I got mad love for my high
school I stole most of my friends are
from high school because we got back in
high schools like it's all you were
either Filipino Mexican or black like if
that's like a third each of our school
so like everyone's like so culturally
diverse and it's like everyone's got
different different backgrounds and [ __ ]
it's um I miss home I miss South Beach
San Diego I don't me to go on a rant
play like people have to like to
drastically different you know feelings
about high school yeah loved it and they
hate it out more on the I hated inside
it's all about the people to be honest
not high school results there we go
what am i I was like trying to find
where to answer and I find about it this
might be our last mission here of the
day what is this by the way I haven't
like this question mark hasn't been
hatching pods yeah okay so this is a
something a little different than what
we've done before but um this one might
be really hard because you have to
manage hordes of mutants and while
destroying these little pods so we'll
see how difficult this
level six on nightmare so no man I want
to go back home
no not home as in like my apartment here
in San Francisco but I want to go back
to San Diego for a minute see all my
homies the weather is probably amazing
over there right now it's so cold here
it is I can't stand it
Sanford's bay area don't got seasons
it's just always 60 something degree
yeah and windy all the time sometimes
arranged that's it
Oh what's up pose Fox night says high
school around 10 to 12 grade was amazing
for me see I got from like 9:00 to 10:00
and then I was like screw this I'm
graduating early I want to deal with a
yeah my brothers did the same yeah I
graduated I like a year earlier in a sec
I don't want to deal with this like
alright man I don't blame you a lot of
people still talking about some days
gone in the chat I played a lot of day
of gone you know because we were
streaming some days on and I felt like
that game had a lot of really cool like
aspects I was very interested in the
story and I cried a lot like I didn't
finish it yet but I cried a lot like
just from the story and the cutscenes
and stuff like that I felt like after a
while though some of the stuff just got
like so repetitive and you know I was
like okay this is cool you know you get
better at doing specific things and then
I'll say alright what's next like what's
the next level things after that the
only thing that really like was super
challenging we're just hoards so you
know you play through enough of the
story and then it's kind of just all
poor it's and if you're not prepared for
those four it's it's pretty challenging
probably one of the more challenging
like zombie games I played in a really
long time for the hoards alone but you
can do cool stuff too like you have
enemy camps you could like drag a hoard
into the enemy camp which was fun to
only work like maybe 1 out of 10 times I
tried to do it but the one that I did
speaking of porridge Maddie's wrong
there like stop destroying our hatching
no this is where they come alive you
know it's easy to look at the guys and
be like that the bad guys but you are
running in there and shooting their
babies I mean there you go they'll get
over it remember they're blown to pieces
yeah I died again yeah so I wasn't
really paying attention the hordes there
so I got [ __ ] it oh my goodness
great dude that says what's the coldest
temperature you've experienced because
in Montreal sometimes gets the negative
forty with the wind
oh man that's that's bad Oh probably
like that's too much yeah well maybe
like 10 degrees Fahrenheit I was in I
used to live in Rhode Island when I was
a little little dumbass kid and it would
snow there oh yeah you coast especially
I mean I think colas was like negative
ten or something like that I went to
visit my brother in Wyoming it's so
random he lives there yeah but oh yeah
one of my first times experiencing snow
too I was like it was one of my first
times and then I instantly knew I hated
it like this is the worst thing ever
made oh I miss snows a lot of fun I
don't mind I see the thing is like I
don't mind when it's cold if it's a if
it looks like it's supposed to be cold
maybe it's like a brain thing or like my
brain sees snow it's like oh it's
supposed to be cold I'll be fine by here
it's like sunny and like wind chills
something's not adding up and that's
like a dissonance in my brain so I could
play knots out if I use a shotgun more I
think that was my problems try use the
assault rifle and wasn't that effective
his blast these pods real quick with a
shot oh
[Applause]
I don't have overdrive son were the last
ones I'll get this one right there
I gotta go I gotta get out of here I
just got to keep running that's the
thing so they're gonna keep chasing me
okay Lisa pods give you yeah yeah oh
there it is Oh
storage containers Oh don't need it
completed yeah each areas gonna have
storage containers and that's how you
like complete the area but really with
what I'm here for is shoot some things I
like I like once you finish the mission
it was like it cleared up yeah they're
all gone just give up
but yeah that's a that's a little bit of
Rage too I've got a little taste of a
little bit of everything in the open
world
I suppose we didn't get the two convoys
we can't really do any main missions but
that's all good there's a there's still
a lot on that map but yeah that was uh
it's chillin playing rage - yeah I have
fun thanks for talking with us thanks
for tuning in and race shoot comes out
tomorrow so keep your eyes peeled for
that make sure you get the game if you
liked what you saw yeah I mean I enjoyed
watching the I played a little bit
earlier it felt really good too so mmm
looking forward to seeing what kind of
crazy things you guys do that's one of
my favorite things right a game comes
out and then everybody will like have
their clips in their moments yeah I like
this I like this so yeah hope you guys
enjoyed the stream we will be back
tomorrow I think we're gonna be playing
somewhere I Tetris 99 tomorrow so we'll
see I'm actually trying to drag Alyssa
into play with us Oh
Alyssa's badass and Tetris I mean
there's a box but yeah have a great day
happy Monday you guys and we'll see you
guys tomorrow at the same time same
place so see you later
[Music]